what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back to talking Thrones for my first
official season 8 update video for those
of you that are new to my channel I just
want to let you know that I will be
making videos all year just like I did
for season 7 I will release several
videos each week and give you as many
updates as possible I love to make
prediction and Theory videos but also
like making videos about the production
of a new season
anytime I receive some new information
about the upcoming season I will let you
know whether its new set locations
filming schedules set photos new actors
casted and pretty much anything else to
do with Game of Thrones I know many of
us are wondering when season 8 will
begin so I will try to answer that
question for you as best as I can today
and I have a few other exciting details
that I think you will enjoy but let's
get the most important thing out of the
way first everybody wants to know when
season 8 will begin so I will give you
the most recent news about the filming
schedule thus far HBO has neither
confirmed nor denied these claims but
The Hollywood Reporter did interview
HBO's programming president and some
other executives from a few other
networks and as far as I know Game of
Thrones will begin filming in October
which is just one month away from today
when they film season 7 they began in
October as well so as of right now we
are on the same schedule as last year
since winter is here in Game of Thrones
they have started filming later than
usual that way they can film during the
winter months
that way it can appear colder with much
more snow on the ground but even though
filming will start in October again that
doesn't mean we will see season 8 in
July because this season will take a
significant amount of more work to
produce season 8 we'll only have six
episodes but a few different people that
work for HBO have said that they plan on
making each episode feature film length
Game of Thrones episodes typically run
around 60 minutes per episode but in
season 8 they are thinking each episode
may be closer to 80 to 90 minutes each
which is great because even though there
is only going to be six episodes if they
are each around 90 minutes long then
that's close to a normal season's worth
of content I firmly believe each episode
in season 8 will look and feel more like
a movie and since Game of Thrones is
turning into this next level television
show cinematically
it will take a lot longer to produce in
post-production we'll give you a quote
from KC boys who is HBO's programming
president and Casey says our production
people are trying to figure out a
timeline for the shoot and how much time
the special effects are going to take
the shooting is already complicated
enough they have to film on several
different continents with all the
technical aspects and the special
effects are a whole other production
period that we're trying to figure out
that is a big factor in all of this
because as the show gets bigger and more
complicated I have to follow the
producers lead and let go of the fact
that we might not be able to get a new
season a game of Thrones
each year they have to do the best show
that they can do and with shows like
Game of Thrones sometimes if you want
the big show and the big scope it takes
a lot longer to make this is definitely
something we have to consider when
waiting for season 8 to premiere they
may take the same amount of time to film
as they did for season 7 but the
post-production for season 8 is going to
take a lot longer what the special
effects team now that the army of the
Dead is south of the wall we're going to
be seeing them a lot more than we have
ever seen them before
and that's the same thing with the
Dragons all of this is done with CGI and
when you are making these epic battles
it can take weeks or even months to work
to create battle scenes with dragons and
thousands of whites plus you have to
choreograph all of the real actors and
extras that are going to be fighting
them if we want to continue getting a
show that is a cinematic phenomena then
we're gonna have to be patient Season
eight will be the last season so I
completely understand if they want to
take their time with this I want the
show to end on a high note just as much
as everybody else when a show ends
poorly it can affect the entire show's
legacy and I certainly do not want that
to happen with Game of Thrones I have
committed so much of my time to this so
I'm praying that it ends in epic fashion
and I want season 8 to blow us away
story wise and cinematically as far as I
know Dane and Dave have finished the
season eight scripts and they have
turned them in so the final season has
its story now we just have to wait for
them to bring it to life I know there
are season eight leaks floating around
out there already but I do not believe
they are real at all I have not read
them all but I was told a bunch of
scenes to me and it sounds fake in my
opinion I think someone wrote them up
themselves as fan fiction because they
knew this
season eight leaks were accurate so they
figured they could pass anything off as
a real leak now but don't believe
everything that you read there is some
other exciting season 8 news that just
came out today thanks to a group of
people in Ireland who follow Game of
Thrones there is a Twitter page called
Irish clones and they are dedicated to
sharing information about the Game of
Thrones locations in Ireland according
to them some of the Game of Thrones sets
are already operational and have begun
preparing to film season 8 next month
one of their tweets says the set in
Corbett Ireland is back up and running
and work is well underway and very busy
the Riverrun castle front is still up
and operational and very busy - and this
is pretty exciting news in my opinion
this must mean Game of Thrones plan on
filming something in Riverrun during
season 8
they also said a lot of work has taken
place on the field facing river runs
castle and I think we're gonna see an
army assemble there I think this can
mean a few different things actually but
I don't want to speculate too much until
I see some actual photos if they are
preparing to film at Riverrun then that
might mean we will see admir Tolly once
again and perhaps he is preparing to
March troops north to help the Starks
fight the army of the Dead now that the
night king in his army are south of the
wall when moving towards Winterfell John
and Daenerys are gonna need every
soldier they can possibly get their
hands on the last time we saw admir
Tolly was at Riverrun with Jaime
Lannister ed mirror was still being held
captive by the phrase but Jaime used him
to gain access inside of the castle that
the blackfish wasn't willing to just
hand over we never actually got to see
what happened to Ed Muir after this
but when Jaime went back to celebrate
with Walder Frey we did get some
information from Walder Frey that stated
where ed Muir currently was this came
together rather well your father would
be placed sure he would be
had me oz back in the south Congo
killing my son by law wouldn't be right
did the family a bad name Walder Frey
told Jaime that he had put ed Muir back
in the cells but as we all know Arya
wiped out all of them at the twins but
we never did see her release ed Muir
Tolley but this could be where Jaime
Lannister comes into play once again
Jaime Lannister is now heading north and
as far as I know he is heading north by
himself
and Jaime may end up stopping by
Riverrun or the twins on his way north
and he may try and persuade others to
help him and come north to Winterfell
but like I said I do not want to
speculate too much right now until I
actually see some photo evidence but I
thought it was very interesting that
they have a crew back at Riverrun set
preparing it for something if you think
you know what they might be doing at
Riverrun leave it down in the comments
because I would like to hear what ideas
you may have about this news but to sum
everything up in this video season 8
preparations have already begun and they
are setting the stage to start filming
in October more news and photos will
start to come out daily very soon now
that things are underway and we might
have a long wait but I am already
getting excited just thinking about some
of the things that we could potentially
see in the final season since the final
six episodes maybe around feature film
length I think we can expect it to be
visually stunning once again I just hope
they crafted the scripts well enough to
tell a cohesive story that makes sense
and is satisfying in some way although
we will probably get a better sweet
ending in the television show too but
either way I will be happy because there
aren't any other shows that I am
dedicated to like I am with Game of
Thrones I hope to see you all continue
this journey with me
so thank you all so much for watching
today's video things are just getting
started with production so make sure you
are subscribed to the channel that way
you can stay up to date with any and
everything Game of Thrones related I
also want to thank you kind people on
patreon who support this channel I
really do appreciate all that you do I
hope everyone has a great day bye
[Music]